And also, I will be deleting this from
chat. Don't joke like this, okay?
Destiny revisits the kill stream. Nick
Fuentes, Lieutenant Corbus, and Britney
Venty. Ethical child porn. This is a
live stream where Destiny debates the
ethics of child porn with Lieutenant
Corbus, who I believe is at the time
around 15.
>> Then yeah, you should be allowed to dox
this dox like that place and even swap
that place. [__] You cannot give me a
situation where doxing someone is going
to be more beneficial than calling the
cops.
>> Oh, I get [__]
>> I need to have like a 12-year-old.
[Laughter]
>> So, he he feeds into he he literally
raids into an admitted small pe who is
farming his minor child
who's being farmed by Drew Pavloo.
>> That's rough. Jesus.
[Music]
Enough goofing around. Godspeed for the
five Canadian had the entire block
bumping Jay off at the function. Can't
wait to hear more. What does that mean?
What is Jay off?
What's that?
J off.
jerking off. Had the entire block
bumping, jerking off at the function.
Oh,
wait. Is that my song?
Wait, that's my song, right?
I completely forgot I did that
career. He still has. Anyway, I've
rambled enough. I'll leave a few videos
in the description by other creators who
have covered Glass in case you want to
watch more about this guy. But outside
of that, let's end this video off with
something special.
>> Something special.
[Music]
Look, he gave you his car. My shifted
ars
waiting on
[Music]
[Applause]
jerking off.
You know that I would wait for you.
>> The fact I'm not 62.
[Applause]
>> All right, enough of this. We have
things we got to go over.
We got [__] we got to touch on. Who the
[__] is DMing me on Discord?
Who the [__]
Okay, well that's settled.
How many viewers are we at? 37 viewers.
Hi guys.
As is tradition.
Should I show the subreddit since I've
been streaming more?
We can show the Reddit a little bit.
I don't think there's been any posts on
it.
What happened? Seriously,
what happened? Seriously. Wow. W listen
guys, if you want to post like a meme or
a clip or a tweet, even if it's like
unrelated to any drama, you just want me
to look at something. I'll put the
Reddit in the chat.
I'll show it a little bit.
I do want to encourage some community. I
know Quean and Queen and Aiden are
really good at this, right?
Queen and Aiden are really good at um
promoting
community interaction and stuff like
that. Um
I am not, you know, I don't think I have
that big of a community, but it would be
nice. It'd be nice to get a little
community going, a little community of
little disgenic freaks. All right,
little community of disgenic freaks.
So, if you guys would like to
participate, uh, there's a Discord. The
Discord's dead as [__] Yeah, let's get
more people in the Discord. We have a
Discord server as well. I'll show the
Discord a little bit. Uh, I'm assuming
all [__] 40 of you are in the server
already.
Join the server. Uh, you can post like
fan art, you can talk with the
community. There's a topic suggestions
channel, and I'll usually go there if I
run out of [__] to cover and see what
you guys are posting.
Um,
what else? What else? What else? What
else?
That's probably it. I don't have like a
Twitter community or something. Um,
I don't really care about Twitter. Like,
like having a community on Twitter to be
fair. Join the Discord, participate in
the Reddit, uh, you know, even in chat.
Just talk in chat. Okay. Let's get the
morale community the morale community
going. Surely. Surely.
So, this Antoz guy, is this a big
account or is this like a nobody glob
shadow?
He has 80,000 followers
and he's tweeting about Lil T only fans.
Only fans must be banned.
Okay, legit question, folks. I got to I
got to ask this because if I'm not the
one to ask this, who will? Who will?
What is the point of the age of consent
if when someone waits till after the age
of consent, people still get upset?
What's even the point?
What's even the point of the age of
consent? Should we just ban sex? Ban sex
until you're married. How about that? I
feel like that would solve the issue.
All these people complaining
freshly 18. Freshly 18. Just ban sex.
Make it so you have to get married.
Lifelong commitment to your partner.
lifelong commitment to your partner. Uh,
make cheating illegal. Um,
what else?
Um,
I don't know. That's it, I guess. I
don't [__] know, dude. Whatever.
Okay, this guy has like 80,000
followers. Okay, that's pretty
significant, I would say. And he posts
on Twitter, Destiny's 14-year-old son
admits, I'm a Nazi. Now, I'm going to
make it abundantly clear. I don't want
to bring people's children into it. Uh,
I am personally uncomfortable, you know,
significantly criticizing Destiny's kid.
I'm not even going to name him.
Obviously, his name is on screen, but
I'm not even going to name him. I'm
personally uncomfortable with that. Am I
going to heavily critique someone else
that does it? Uh, maybe slightly. Maybe
slightly.
Okay. Maybe slightly.
Okay. However, uh I'm just personally
I'm not going to attack him because he's
young. He's probably going to have silly
beliefs. Uh I don't think he should be
scrutinized for these. Um you know, when
he's an adult, maybe when he's an adult,
uh you know, and he has more agency and
stuff like that, uh I think it's fine to
criticize him. But as of now, I'm just
personally I'm personally against it. I
don't want to be uh you know, he needs
to be totally ignored and nobody should
be propping him up in interviews and
debates. That is my opinion precisely.
That is my opinion precisely. Uh I think
yeah, I agree completely. People should
not be giving this kid attention. Um
what is going on with him is actually
really disgusting. He's been tweeting
out. Um like people are DMing him like
the videos of Destiny sucking [__] and
[__] Uh I feel bad for him. I feel bad
for him. I know people will people will
kind of freak out saying like, "Oh, he's
admitting to be a Nazi or whatever." And
it's like, dude, like, come on. Like, I
don't know. This is just,
come on. Like, I feel bad for the kid. I
I feel I I do feel bad for the kid. I'm
not going to criticize him. I'm not
going to really talk about him. That's
not the point I'm bringing this up. To
be clear, I want to make it abundantly
clear. Okay? I want to make it
abundantly clear. And also, I will be
deleting this from chat. Don't joke like
this. Okay? I feel like I feel like I
need to draw the line somewhere. Jokes
like this, uh, pedophile jokes directed
at someone's in real life kid, I feel
like are are where I personally will
draw the line. Okay, jokes are jokes. I
understand that was a joke. Uh, however,
however, we are going to draw the line
somewhere and I think we're going to
draw the line at that. Uh, I don't want
to criticize this kid. I don't want to
[__] on his kid. Okay? I understand it's
a joke and I don't want to ban jokes
entirely. That's not what I'm going to
do. All right? But to be clear, I am
going to draw the line somewhere and
just right now that is the line. I don't
want to encourage that type of behavior.
Okay? Don't want to don't want to
encourage that at all. I understand it's
a joke. Absolutely not going to
encourage that. So, not so aerodite. Uh,
which is Destiny's number one ball
washer, ball gargler
all over the [__] nuts. Can we maybe
leave kids out of it? Now, generally,
generally, I agree with this. However,
however, folks,
however,
generally I agree with this. Generally,
I agree with this.
All right.
Generally, I agree with this.
However,
what is this from 6 years ago?
Destiny revisits the killstream. Nick
Fuentes, Lieutenant Corbus, and Britney
Venty.
Ethical child porn. This is a live
stream
where Destiny
debates the ethics of child porn with
Lieutenant Corbus, who I believe is at
the time around 15.
So I I just feel like personally I just
feel like personally.
Okay.
I just feel like personally uh when
you're the one saying this, can we maybe
leave kids out of it
when Destiny has a history of, you know,
but you're not going to talk about
Destiny. I understand that. And I kind
of point this out. So, I I make a tweet.
I respond, "Yeah, we should probably
leave kids out of it, huh? Probably
pretty bad that Destiny raided into a
self-described pedophile reacting to his
14-year-old debating. Or what about the
time Destiny debated Lieutenant Corbus,
who was underage, about the ethics of
child porn? Pretty bad, huh?" And I
include a screenshot of Destiny raiding
into food shops when Food Shops is uh
gazing lovingly at this this epic debate
with Drew Pavlo and Destiny's Child.
Now, I stand by this 100%. Um, I don't
like Arerodite. I don't like Arerodite.
Um, I don't like Arerodite in so far as
like I feel like she's dishonest, right?
The only person, and I I will I'll be
honest, okay, one of the things that
annoys me, people say repeatedly, people
say repeatedly, oh, the the only one in
the Destiny sphere who's honest about
what he does is Dan. Dan is not honest.
Okay, Dan is 1,000% not honest. Dan,
when you accuse him of doxing people,
he's he's avoidant. Uh Dan acts like
likes to act like he's above it all,
like he's the good guy, stuff like that
when he's doing the shame [__] I don't
see Dan as honest at all. I see Dan as
incredibly dishonest. Uh Dan is
literally no better than bad empanata.
Dan will go after people's sponsors. Dan
will dox people. Dan will do all of this
[__] I don't I don't see him as as
honest about being dishonest at all.
Right. The only person in this sphere
that I see is like somewhat honest about
Destiny is is Connor. Connor points.
I think Connor points is the only one
who's honest about it cuz I feel like
he's willing to uh he's willing to admit
when he's wrong. He had a debate with
Dickers where he admitted he was in the
wrong. He's willing to take his L's and
he's willing to admit when he thinks
Destiny is doing something like stupid
or weird. He does the same like genre of
like coward behavior that Arerodite does
where it's like um it's like oh what
Destiny did is bad but like I'm still
going to stand by him and even though it
goes against like every single [__]
principle you have right um so he still
does that but he's he is by far in my
opinion in my opinion uh he is by far
the most honest actor in the Destiny
sphere I think right um but no like this
is just completely [__] dishonest on
us like can we leave kids out of it? And
it's like, bro, Destiny doesn't leave
his kid out of it. There's a tweet. I'm
not going to pull it up cuz again, I
don't want to I don't want to give, you
know, significant attention to the kid,
but there's a tweet where someone calls
Destiny a deadbeat father. And Destiny's
reply is to post a selfie of him and his
kid. And it's like, Destiny is the one
bringing his kid into this. Destiny is
the one doing this, right?
But, you know, whatever.
This is kind of like, you know,
what are what are our thoughts on this?
Cuz I feel pretty strongly about this
take. It's just like everyone around
Destiny is a [__] like spineless
hypocrite. I feel like including food
shops.
That's just me.
Also, I bought um I bought Baja Blast uh
Zero Sugar today. I'm very excited about
that.
Lynn says, "I don't care." Lynn, I'm
going to have a feeling you're going to
be very upset by this stream. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, Lynn.
I have a feeling you're not going to
enjoy a lot of the things I have to say
in this stream.
is zero sugar socks. Listen, I like I
like fizzy drink.
I like fizzy drink. However, I'm not
going to [__] drink like 400 [__]
calories.
That's insane. Obviously, I'm going to
buy the zero sugar option. It tastes the
same. It tastes the same to me.
I'm perfectly fine. Listen, if aspartame
takes like 5 years off my life, I'm
perfectly fine with that. I can I can
justify that to be able to to have a
fizzy drink every now and again. That
doesn't make me [__] insanely like
diabetic. Okay.
All right. Well, it seems like you guys
all agree. I love being glazed. Let's
look at this tweet, then. Let's look at
this tweet then.
So, food shops, this is a clip of food
shops by Chir Mullet. Pedo adjacent
streamer Food Shops advocates for
swatting. After giving weak rebuttals to
the claims of being a pedophile, she
volunteers two scenarios that warrant
doxing.
>> Number one, if the person is a doxer
themselves, okay, number
>> if the person's a doxer themselves, uh
you should report them, right, to
whatever service. Most services don't
allow doxing. Don't permit doxing. you
know, if you're against doxing, uh,
report them to the service. Um, an eye
for an eye makes the world go blind.
Okay? Where pedo adjacent? Well, no, she
she listen, it's a funny term. I'm fine.
I'm fine. Listen,
there are there are scenarios where I
don't feel bad if someone's doxed. I
don't think anybody should be doxed, to
be clear. Okay? To be clear, I don't
think anybody should be doxed. I don't
think there is any scenario you can give
me where calling the cops or getting the
authorities involved is is less
effective than doxing. Okay.
But there are there are a few scenarios
where I just won't feel bad. I'll still
stand by my principle like no, don't dox
people.
But if it's like a pedophile that gets
doxed,
if it's a like a zufile, if it's an
animal abuser, if it's anybody who is
like insanely just like violent
and stuff like that essentially, right?
Stuff like that. It's like I don't I'm
not going to feel bad if you're doxed,
but I'm still going to be principally
against it, right? It's the same way if
a if a [__] pedophile gets jumped on
the street. It's like, yeah, I'm not
really going to feel bad if they get
beat the [__] up in the middle of like
Chicago or something, right? Uh,
however, you're like, yeah, I'm
principally against like assaulting
people in broad daylight. I think that's
like pretty bad for society as a whole,
right? So, like doxers getting doxed,
yeah, I'm not going to feel bad for
that. However, you know, fighting fire
with fire, doing [__] eye for an eye,
all of these things, like obviously
that's not going to help anyone, right?
pretty sure that's that's not going to
help anyone. But let's let's keep uh
let's keep listening.
>> Number one, if the person is a doctor
themselves, okay, number two, if you've
seen a a scenario if you've seen a
scenario online where um for example,
you see some domestic abuse happening
and you
>> you see domestic abuse happening.
Wait, you see you see domestic abuse
happening.
Domestic abuse happening.
>> I don't wish to bring any
>> domestic abuse.
Domestic abuse.
Around the end of 2011, Destiny sexually
assaulted a woman on his live stream.
I'm not
>> Oh.
Oh.
>> using the word allegedly here because we
have video of him doing it and he has
openly admitted that it was sexual
assault. I would say that in my
streaming career in the past, like
totally publicly, like I completely and
totally likely assaulted a girl on
stream before for like [__] five
minutes or whatever. I got super [__]
drunk and was like grabbing her [__]
breast the entire time. Later, Destin
Huh?
Huh? Wait, wait. So, am I am I missing
something? Hold on. Let's play that
again.
>> If you've seen a a scenario if you've
seen a scenario online where um for
example, you see some domestic abuse
happening and
>> if you see domestic abuse happening
>> around the end of 2011, Destiny sexually
assaulted a woman on his live stream.
I'm not using the word allegedly here.
Huh?
Jacob, he can Listen, here's the thing
with Destiny. He can 100% move on,
right? Um,
let's even use [__] FEMA as an
example. They're in chat, right? Uh,
they've literally doxed like [__]
12-year-olds or something.
They've literally docked like little
kids and nobody talks about it anymore.
You want to know why? Because they
corrected the behavior.
They corrected the behavior, right?
Nope. My dog is freaking the [__] out. I
don't know if you guys can hear that.
They have corrected the behavior.
They've moved on and they've bettered
themselves and they haven't done it, you
know, again, right?
All right. So, it's like, what what are
you supposed to say? Am I still going to
call Femos a doxer? No. Okay. Well, fe
you threatened to do what? You threaten
[__] What was it? You threatened to dox
this like little black kid. I forget his
name. He was like a legit. You threaten
to dox this like little legit. I was
making fun of you. I forget his name.
Uh, can he move past these clips?
Obviously. Um, but you know, they're on
the internet. You can still use them to
you can still bring them up. Who cares?
It's like I'm never going to complain,
right?
I've gotten a different time stamp.
Let's see.
>> Towards his ex-wife, and he also
admitted to choking out another one of
his exes multiple times. However, he
claims that this was done in
self-defense.
>> Cuz you better [__] believe I had to
[__] choke her out a few [__]
times.
>> Finally,
>> Huh?
Huh?
Huh.
But no, I I think these clips are
relevant in terms of uh showing that
Destiny has not really changed. Not that
he's still sexually harassing or
assaulting people. I don't think that's
the case. Um, but he's getting worse.
Uh, he is harassing Cherry. I believe
1000% he is harassing Cherry. Uh, he is
continuing to uh harass and belittle
Cherate Cherry on his offline DG chat on
Twitter, in Jtock's uh kick chat
occasionally. All of these things uh
which is pretty disgusting in my
opinion, especially when she's accusing
you of sexual impropriy. um you should,
you know, probably be [__] quiet if
if Cherry has any case against you,
which, you know, I'm not going to make
any definitive claims on. There's not a
police report that I've been able to
see. You know, I'm never going to make
uh I'm never going to make any
definitive claims, right, uh about that
unless I see something in front of me.
Uh however, this person's accusing you
of sexual impropriy and they claim that
they have a case against you. Uh and you
have admitted fault about the Cherry
[__] I believe. So,
And it's like, okay, Lynn, to be clear,
nobody deserves to be [__] harassed.
Doesn't matter if you're like insanely
schizophrenic.
Cherry leaked others nudes. Is there any
proof for this at all? Where is there
proof for this?
Where is Where is the pro? Kelly Jean.
Okay. Is there a screenshot? Is there
evidence or are you going off of Kelly
Jean who doesn't like Cherry
who has lied before?
No. Exactly. Does Kelly Jean have proof
or is she the proof?
Exactly. If you can provide me proof,
yeah, I'll disavow that. I'll even stop
talking to Cherry because I think that
is a a line that I will very clearly
draw. That is a line I will very uh
clearly draw.
I believe Kelly when she's petty. Okay.
So, no, you should not unless there's
evidence. You should not just believe
someone's word. Uh that is [__] So,
no. Unless I have seen evidence, the
claim that cherries spread other
people's nudes, as far as I understand,
is completely false. And you should not
be spreading that. That is harmful
rhetoric. That is completely harmful
rhetoric. You're [__] You're
[__]
DMs. Okay. Only say DMs after you send
me something. I look at my DMs, I don't
see anything. Hey, what is this?
So, we have Destiny.
Subpina Cher's accusation only matters
because it was coordinated with Pixies.
This is the third time she's me to me.
Lol W. Uh, she's generally self-aware,
but right now she's no uh she has no one
grounding her and helping her stay sane.
The people around her are all just using
her to weaponize her in a certain
direction. And instead of giving her
healthy good advice, they're just
fostering her obsessions and insanities
because it's epic. Like all day today,
she's just ranting and raving about
Aerodite in Jtock's Discord and [__]
And they're all clapping along with her.
It'll continue until she either has a
huge break huge breakdown or JTO. Why?
What are we doing here?
When Jtock regularly deletes all of the
DMs. Okay. Again, Lynn, if you don't
have proof, I'm going to make this very
clear. Okay. I'm going to make this
abundantly clear actually. If you guys
have a claim for something, show me
proof. Send me a screenshot of this
evidence. If your evidence is some third
party saying something, Lyn, I like you.
Okay? I like you, Lynn. All right. I
think you're generally pretty funny. I
think you're generally pretty funny, and
I enjoy having you in chat, and I don't
want to lose you in chat, but I'm going
to be I'm going to make it abundantly
clear. If you're going to make false
claims in my chat that have absolutely
no [__] evidence behind them,
accusing someone of egregious crimes of
revenge porn with no evidence, I will
ban you. Okay? So, let's let's make it
very clear. If you have the opinion that
Cherry sent revenge porn around and you
have no evidence behind it, keep that
opinion to yourself because I will ban
you from chat. Not just about the cherry
[__] okay? This is a very broad
spectrum. Unless you have evidence for
something, do not claim it in my chat or
I will ban you.
So, it's fine if you think this way. I
cannot police your thought. I cannot
police your thought, but unless you have
evidence for something, keep it to
yourself because I will ban you because
I am not I'm absolutely [__] not
going to be the facilitating uh
facilitate any sort of uh you know,
claims like that without evidence. And
to be clear, if Cherry knowingly sent
revenge porn of women's nudes to other
people, I will 1,000%
say I that is a despicable thing to do.
That is illegal. That is [__] crazy.
Cherry is a hypocrite and I will
distance myself. I will never talk to
this person again. I will never be
associated with this person again
because I do draw the line there. I
think going against someone's consent
like that uh is very disgusting. So, to
be clear, if there is evidence for this
claim, I will 1,000% disavow and back
off.
Almost genius. This is not the [__]
This is not the stream for you if you're
going to complain about me playing
10-year-old clips, okay? This is not the
stream for you. You can comp you've been
complaining about it for 10 minutes.
You've been complaining about it for 10
minutes. sit down and enjoy the content
or uh or [__] off. I don't know what to
tell you. I don't know what to tell you.
So, Lynn, I'd love to have you in chat.
Again, this is not specifically for
Lynn. All right? But just anybody, if
you don't have evidence for a claim,
don't spread it. Unless it's like
obviously a joke and you can tell it's a
joke. If you're if obviously there's a
difference between a joke and a serious
claim, if you're trying to spread a
serious claim uh and without evidence,
just keep it to yourself. I'm not going
to police your thought. I'm not going to
critique your thought.
Um, but I just don't want to facilitate
stuff like that. Okay.
To be clear, I will not facilitate like
false claims like that. I think that's
bad to do.
So, keep it to yourself. I won't police
your thought. You can think it. You can
believe 100% that uh that Cherry has
done that. Uh, however, uh, just don't
voice it.
All right. So, let's keep watching this
clip. and you think that someone is in
immediate danger, then yeah, you should
be allowed to dox this dog.
Rumor has it that you aren't even a cat.
Any proof?
[__] Wrong one. [__]
[__]
[__] Wrong. [__]
[__] [__] There it is. There it is.
There we go.
Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Here we go. Belly on
day one. Tummy on day one. Tummy on day
one. Jesus. Jesus.
>> Like that place and even swat that
place. [__] Right. If you
>> and even swat that place. Now this is
the big contention I have with this
clip. Let's play that again cuz I know.
Let's go to the swatting part. I'll I'll
play it all to the swatting part
>> where um for example, you see some
domestic abuse happening and you think
that someone is in immediate danger,
then yeah, you should be allowed to dox
this dox like that place and even swat
that place. [__] Right? If you think
that and send the police to that,
>> you should dox a place if there is
domestic or or you should swat a place.
Sorry. You should swat a place if
there's domestic violence going on. To
be clear, like I say in this tweet, I'll
just read out my tweet because this is
pretty much my take. Uh, quote, "If
domestic abuse is happening, you should
be able to dox that place. If is the
address being made public going to stop
the domestic abuse? What would be more
helpful here? Publicly announcing the
address or silently calling the cops.
Also, Swatting is calling it a fake
threat. Everything this person says is
complete nonsense, and they have no
moral argument to back any of it up.
They just want to justify Destiny doxing
people critical of him. This pedophile
is genuinely subhuman filth." This is
all true. This is all true.
If there is domestic abuse happening,
what the [__] is doxing going to do?
What the [__] is doxing going to do in
that situation that is going to solve
the issue?
Exactly. Unironically, femas.
Unironically, virtue signaling publicly
helps more than calling the police.
True. True. This is the same [__]
[__] that all of these people um like
the even even the [__] pedophile
hunters with like the Roblox [__]
right? It's like doxing the pedophiles
will help. No, it won't. Doxing people
is not going to get [__] results,
especially for illegal [__] like this.
What's going to help? Going on Twitter
and saying, "Oh, this guy's hitting his
wife. Here's his address." Or calling
the cops and filing a [__] police
report. What which one of these is going
to be more helpful?
Which one of these is going to be more
helpful? is one of them gonna
potentially, you know, get the police to
the residents and, you know, maybe stop
the domestic, you know, file a, you
know, get the process for filing a
restraining order, all this [__] And
then one of them is going on Twitter and
saying, "Oh, guys, this guy's hitting
his girlfriend."
One of these is is significantly
one of these is significantly more
helpful than the other.
You cannot, you literally cannot, you
cannot give me a situation where doxing
someone is going to be more beneficial
than calling the cops.
You absolutely cannot
make the claim that you you you cannot.
There is no examples. And I I beg you
guys to try obviously give examples in
the chat. I'll [__] respond to them.
I am I am pretty hard stanced on this.
There is no scenario which doxing
someone, leaking someone's private
information, their full name, their
address, their friends, their family,
their workplace, whatever, whatever it
might be, their face even, there is no
situation where any of that is going to
be better than calling the cops. And if
you're doxing someone for something that
isn't illegal, then why the [__] are you
doxing them? Why the [__] are you doing
that? Who is being benefited there?
Right? If there is something illegal,
like a domestic dispute going on, what
if the cops are corrupt? Okay. Yeah, we
live in [__] Gotham. We live in
[__] Gotham. We got to call Batman
instead, dude.
[__] yeah, man. Hell yeah.
But the cops are corrupt.
Brain rot take. Okay. Brain rot take. I
don't care. I won. You're [__] gay.
Okay. you're [__] gay and [__]
But again, this is just like a brain
rotted [__] argument. And then the
latter half of what they say, you should
be able to swap that place. To be clear,
swatting is not calling the cops. SWAT
is not calling the cops. SWAT is making
a false claim to the police to the point
where they have to send a SWAT team
under false pretenses to harass someone,
to threaten someone. Right? That is what
SWAT is. SWAT is you call the cops. You
say, "Hey, this guy's this guy's
hostages. There's a guy with a gun in
this house. He has hostages and he's
going to kill them." Or, "There's a guy
in this house. He has a [__] bomb.
There's a guy in this building. He has a
[__] bomb. he's going to do something
right when there's no actual, you know,
crime taking place. That is what
swatting is. So, this person trying to
make a pro doxing argument, trying to
justify doxing. Okay, this person is
trying to justify doxing when they are
misusing terms to try to get to that
point. They're saying, "Oh, you should
be able to swat someplace." SWAT is
never good. Swatting is making a false
claim to the cops to harass someone.
That is what swatting is.
You can get in legal trouble for
unjustifiably swatting someone. Swatting
is inherently unjustified. That is what
swatting is. Swatting is making a false
call to the cops to to send a SWAT team
somewhere to harass someone. They do not
understand the terms that they're using.
They are trying desperately to make a
prodoxing argument to justify what
Destiny is doing and they are [__] it
up because they are too [__] to
understand the terms that they're using.
So, no. To answer to to answer the
little hypothetical that food shops gave
here, you should not dock someone that
is in a domestic dispute. You should
probably, and call me crazy here, you
should probably call the cops.
You should probably just call the cops.
And no, you should never swat someone
because swatting someone means you're
calling in a false claim.
And even even let's let's use this
example. If someone's in a domestic
dispute,
what is the [__] warranting a SWAT
team? Even if you call a SWAT team to a
[__] domestic, I believe that's
unwarranted as well. Call in a [__]
like two cops could probably deal with
that. Just break up the fight. This is
like just such a deranged, [__]
[__] argument. And again, I need to
point out the the inherent hypocrisy
here. this person out of anybody online,
people would gladly justify their docs.
People would gladly justify their docks.
People would gladly justify their docs
for the insane [__] that they've done in
the that they've said. People would
gladly do that. They self-prescribed
themselves as POCD. They self-prescribe
prescribed themselves lollycon to deal
with their POCD and they decided to jerk
off to lollycon for years. They don't
know what PCD is. They don't know how to
deal with it. They just wanted an excuse
to jerk off to what they describe. This
isn't my description. Okay, this isn't
my description. This is their
description. They just wanted an excuse
to jerk off to what they describe as
drawn child porn.
Uh, Green, I understand to some extent.
I think I think you as a citizen do have
some obligation to some extent. Maybe
not online, but like in person, if you
know if you if you know a domestic's
going on, yeah, call the cops. I think
that's fair.
Online, I can understand someone not
wanting to get involved. I personally
don't want to get involved online. I'm
not going to involve getting involved in
any crime. the moment something gets
serious to a point of a crime. Uh yeah,
I'm disconnecting.
Yeah, like in real life if you hear your
neighbor like [__] beating the [__]
out of their wife. Yeah, call the cops.
I don't care.
I don't give a [__] Yeah, call the
cops. Sure, why not?
Yeah, this is just like a completely
[__] argument that they're they're
doing.
Again, they have literally no moral
argument for for anything.
What is POCD? POCD, to explain briefly,
PC. Okay. A lot of people will say PCD
is fake. Uh I'm under the impression
it's real. I think Oh, [__] [__] [__]
[__] [__]
God, God, God.
>> I don't like the juice. Okay.
P OCD is pedophile OCD, pedophilic OCD,
pedophilia OCD, whatever.
Um, essentially what it is, OCD is not
just like you want to be organized and
stuff like that, right? Uh, OCD can be
like anxiety of things, right? So, if
you have a consistent fear of a certain
thing, uh, it can be like a fear of
leaving your oven on or a fear of not
locking your door, if you're constantly
afraid of maybe even being killed, if
you're constantly afraid that someone's
like about to kill you. So, you're kind
of paranoid a little bit. PCD is
specific to pedophilia. PCD does not
mean you are a pedophile. POCD is the
fear of being a pedophile, right?
Um POCD is the anxiety uh that you are a
pedophile. So the fear of it, it does
not mean you actually have uh pedophilic
disorder or whatever. It is the fear
that you are attracted to children.
You're not actually attracted to them.
It is the fear that like, dude, what if
I'm a pedophile? [__] [__] [__]
Right?
Why do you believe foods doesn't have
it? Okay, if you're scared of being a
pedophile,
you Okay, let let's walk through this.
Let's walk through this. I don't believe
food shops have it uh has it. I don't
even think they've ever been diagnosed
for it. And I don't believe any uh
therapist would ever tell them or
encourage them to act on their impulses
of jerking off to anything even slightly
resembling child porn uh to deal with
those impulses. To be clear, but even
past that, right? Even past that, food
shops describes themselves having POCD.
And the way they treat themselves with
POCD is to willingly look up lollycon,
which they describe as drawn child porn,
and to jerk off to it. And they have
jerked off to it consistently for what
they describe as years. Okay?
So, if you are scared of being a
pedophile, in my mind, it makes
absolutely no [__] sense
uh to encourage those feelings and to
consistently masturbate and jerk off uh
and come and shoot your little your
little white white goo everywhere uh to
what you describe and what you think is
drawn child porn.
And let's even go into what drawn child
porn even means because I don't think
that's what LOI is. I think child porn
is a very specific thing. Drawn child or
child porn. Let's let's let's talk about
what child porn is. Okay. Child porn is
the filmed exploitation and abuse of a
child that is filmed and then
distributed for profit. This child is
going to be traumatized. This child is
going to be ruined uh for a while unless
they get significant help generally
speaking. Right? Child porn is abuse.
Child porn is the uh filmed abuse of a
child. Irreversible damage. You are
filming the irreversible damage to a
child. Okay. So, when they describe what
they jerk off to as drawn child porn, it
probably speaks to what they think
they're doing. It probably speaks to
what they think in their head they are
doing and they are encouraging
themselves to do. What they think they
are doing. They think they are watching
a child be abused and they are enjoying
it.
It's exposure therapy. You don't
understand. That's not how that works.
That's not how that works for POCD.
That's not how that works for any OCD
as far as I understand it.
So, no. If you self-prescribe yourself
as pedophilic OCD and then your fix to
that is self-prescribing yourself to
jerk off to LOI, which you describe as
drawn child porn. Yeah. I I I'm going
to, you know, I'm going to, you know,
who's that manga artist got caught with
lollipop porn and child porn? No clue.
I'm not a manga guy. I don't know. Uh
but yeah, to be clear, I don't even
think loy's drawn child porn. I think
using the term child porn is uh inherent
to like abuse, right? I think loi is
something significantly less bad. Uh
there's no harm in the creation of loi.
Um, you can argue that there's harm in
the distribution of LOI, which I would
10,000% agree with. I think the
distribution of LOI and the community
that Lai is formed is probably super
harmful uh to the perpetuation of
sexualization of children online. Uh,
however, the creation of these two
things are insanely different. Wildly
different. Wildly different. Right? So,
I don't even think they're correlated at
all. Right?
Um, obviously for shortorthhand I'm
never going to complain. It's the same
thing when you call like a lollycon a
pedophile. Like technically, yeah, I
disagree. I don't think jerking off to
loi inherently means you're a pedophile.
Um, but like if someone calls a lollycon
a pedophile, it's fine shortorthhand.
The same way if someone calls loi drawn
child porn, it's fine shortorthhand. I'm
not going to definition [__] that hard,
right? I think it's fine shorthand. I
think it's whatever.
I'm guessing that they don't like me
too.
And you can tell me if I cross the line
or if I'm racist. I try to keep an open
mind. I put them all into a camp, but
it's my concentration that wasn't really
there all along. I know I could treat
you better
and I can probably have been a better
better friend. Tell me, is it too late
to try? I know I made you cry. And a few
million Jews are dead. But I know I
could treat you better
if I get a second chance.
>> I'll stop fighting shoes.
Big point here is that food shops likes
to scream from the rooftops about her
attraction. At some point, ironically,
painting yourself as a pedo isn't a
joke. It's legit uh legitimate catharsis
for her. Uh, to be clear, I think I
agree with Resi on this. Um, I don't I
think Food Shops is a pedophile. I
10,000. Yeah, I agree. I think Food
Shops is a pedophile. Um, do I think
that they're ever going to rape a kid? I
don't think so. Um, does that make it
any more better?
Uh, not really. When they're indulging
in things like lollycon, um, I think if
you are a pedophile, the only correct
option for you is chemical castration.
Uh, you should be self-aware enough to
know, hey, I have an attraction. Um, I
don't know if I'm going to be able to
control it. I'm going to get chemically
castrated. I think that's perfectly
fine. That is a perfectly fine option.
Uh, and I get food shops is mostly doing
that with HRT. Their shriveled up little
Asian [__] is getting even more
shriveled uh by abusing HRT. Um,
however, they're obviously still uh
sexually deviant to some degree. Uh, so
I don't think the HRT is enough to to
consider chemical castration. Uh, it
might cut their sperm count down. It
might make them infertile. Uh, but I
don't think that's enough. I think if
they genuinely are a pedophile and they
genuinely have an attraction to
children, uh, they should get chemically
castrated. I believe that
wholeheartedly. Uh, this is the same
opinion I have for for any pedophile. If
you have an attraction to children, um,
I don't think, again, I'm pretty I'm
pretty woke on the pedophile [__]
right? If you have an attraction to
children, like you don't need to [__]
kill yourself. You don't need to die.
You don't need to do any of that. Uh
yeah, go [__] talk to a therapist.
Look into chemical castration. Um you
don't even need to tell anybody. This is
not something you need to be proud of.
This is not something you need to, you
know, love yourself. Be self-aware
enough uh and and you know, empa
empathetic enough to children who are
abused uh to just get chemically
castrated. I believe that. So yeah, I
don't think the HRT is enough. I think
food shops needs to go one step further.
Max, what are you sending me?
What is this?
Rape is the most intense kind of
enjoyment. Women is our oxygen. Thanks.
I guess I
W
I guess
[Laughter]
W I guess, dude. I don't know.
Thanks, Federal Rape, for showing me
this. I'm joining the server. Yeah, join
the Discord, folks. We are a We are a
bustling community.
We are a bustling community.
And again, I I feel like I need to point
out, right? I feel like I need to point
out one of the reasons that food shops
likes Lollcon is the power imbalance
between an adult and a child. The the
idea of an an adult taking advantage of
a child is what turns them on. This is
not something that happens specifically
in Lolly's shed. Uh what turns them on
is the real world abuse of power uh that
happens between an adult and a child
when a child is raped. So um you know
just feel like I need to feel like I
need to point that out. Uh and again I
feel like we've lost the sauce a little
bit but again uh yeah their doxing take
here is just complete complete and utter
just like retardation. This makes no
sense.
This makes no sense.
Uh, is there any other tweets I should
go over before we move on to the
content? Because I do want to watch
I do want to watch there Mr. Girl
Collins. It'll be a bit of a slow day.
We'll have a casual day. Bit of a slow,
relaxed stream.
Are there any other tweets? put put in
topic suggestions if there's any other
tweets, any other clips.
What is this?
Also, if you guys can
if you guys can uh a better way to clip
stuff on Twitter. So, it says X.com. If
you just put the word cancel behind X,
cancel,
this is a Twitter alternative that has
the same linking, you know, structure.
So any link if you just put cancel after
it, it'll show up like this. And this
way you don't need to be logged in to
view Twitter. You don't need to be
logged in to view the tweets, stuff like
that. You can view entire threads. If
you do clip, um, you know, I can
obviously just like type in the cancel
after. It's fine. Um, but I would
suggest you use this because you don't
need you don't need an account and I'm
obviously not logged into anything on
this browser that I use for streaming.
So if you're clipping something and you
know you want to just be I suppose you
know uh generous generous to me put
cancel after it'll just make it you know
slightly slightly easier slightly
easier.
Okay, let me um
Okay, I think we might need to view the
actual tweet instead for this. I just
shilled this website and it's [__]
up. So, this is not a good look for me.
Uh, so at food shops, burns the bridge
with moral.
This is my old account, but whatever.
Ironically, fits the bill for one.
Writes pedophile manifesto. Desire for a
12-year-old. attracted the power
imbalance seeks out pedophiles to talk
to. When will we realize she's bragging
about it in our faces? the pedto and the
um lolli content and um this is the
stuff that um I felt really really
strongly on and I didn't want to private
them um because I felt really strongly
on them um and I wanted to own my past
and um I just wanted to keep it up
because I feelings about the follow I'm
going to have my principles and yeah I
didn't care about what anybody else
thought.
>> A cute little girl that I can wrap my
arms around.
So, you like being like in the dominant
role?
>> Yes.
>> Oh, like you're like big spoon is what
you're saying.
>> Oh, I get you.
>> I need to have like a 12-year-old.
>> It gets me every time.
>> Or whatever.
>> Is like Do you mean like the aesthetic
or just like the the the kids?
Um, probably it's definitely the power
difference. It It is more of the power
difference more than anything else.
>> I was reaching out to organizations that
was
>> like the power difference between an
adult and a minor,
>> not just like random [__] Um and uh
yeah and and they were like actually
talking like these were people who
actually um searched up actual you know
CP and stuff like that like like these
were how crazy like these people were
you know what I mean?
>> Um like this is how high quality it was.
>> You talk to organizations that deal with
ways that we deal with child predators.
>> Um
>> like actual legitimate organizations
that advocate for like aggression.
Whatever is okay.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. So, so
>> wow. W And now she did do that Q&A.
Dude, I tried watching that Q&A.
I tried I tried watching that Q&A. It's
just so [__] boring. I I will never
understand what what some people get out
of food shops. I'm almost half tempted
to to, you know, say that they're
botting their viewers because I
genuinely uh, you know, I'm not
obviously not a serious claim. I think
they are legitimately getting viewers.
You know, ultimately I'm happy for them.
I think content creation uh is a is a
wonderful job. I enjoy doing it. Um but
yeah, I I legitimately cannot fathom how
some people can enjoy their content
legitimately.
>> Having spicy thumbnails and calling me a
dumbass or something. All right, but
calling me a PDF on a thumbnail when we
have a bridge is too far. Okay.
>> So, I can't call them a pedophile, but
they can they can call themselves one.
Okay. Okay. I get it now. I get it now.
>> This is too far. Okay. So, I messaged
him. I was like, "Yo, I'm not okay with
this." And he was like, "Okay, I'll
change it." And there's this what?
He just calls me PDF
in the title, which again, to be clear,
um, yeah, to be clear, and I'm I'll be
perfectly honest about this, food shops
asked me to change the first thumbnail.
I was going to change it. I was going to
change it. Okay. They asked me cordially
like, "Hey, can you change this?" I was
like, "Yeah, I'll change that." You
know, my bad. Obviously, I don't make my
thumbnails. My editor does it all. I'll
change the thumbnail. I don't care.
However, uh the moment they started
justifying doxing, uh I have a hard
line. There are few there are very few
things there are very few things that I
have a hard line on. I'm okay with
people lying. I I was perfectly fine
with food shops uh lying to my face.
lying to my face about Destiny, lying to
my face multiple times, perfectly fine
with that. I can handle people lying
because if they're obviously in private,
I think it's different. But if you're
lying publicly on a live stream to me,
you're not really lying to me. You're
just lying to the audience, you know?
So, I don't see that as a big deal. I
don't care. It makes you look bad to
your audience if they care about that
sort of thing. Um,
I can handle them being pro Destiny,
right? Uh, I'm I'm friends with people
who are pro Destiny, right?
I I'm friends with people in real life
that like Destiny. One of my IRL friends
unironically uh is a big fan of like
Destiny and Short Fat Otaku. I was
driving in his car and he's like, "Dude,
let me show you this guy." And he starts
playing cuz he has like a he has like a
mount for his phone. He starts playing a
short fat otaku video while we're
driving around and he's like, "Dude,
look at this short fat otaku guy. I'm a
big fan of this guy." And he starts
showing me this guy's content. It's like
I'm friends with these people in real
life. I can handle it. I don't care that
much. I don't care that much, right?
Like, I'm fine I'm fine pe with people
being friends with or not I'm fine with
people liking Destiny's content.
Perfectly fine with that. I don't even
care if some of you guys like Destiny's
content. Who cares? The only I I the
only thing I care about and even even
then it's not a deal breakaker is I just
would I would prefer it if Destiny fans
acknowledge the [__] that he does rather
than just try to sweep for it, blindly
defend it, stuff like that. That's what
I would prefer.
But, you know, we obviously don't live
in a perfect world. Um, the thing I I I
I have a hard line on like,
you know, non-consensual [__] and um and
doxing. I think those are my I probably
have more hard lines. I'd have to sit
down and think about it, right?
Are we really going to condemn every
normie? No, I think if you if you watch
someone, you're fine. I don't care. Um,
but the very few hard lines I have are
like non-consensual [__] if you're
sending like non-consensual nudes, if
you're uh you know sexually harassing,
sexually assaulting people, um if you're
doing anything like that, uh and like
prodoxing [__] I think people have a
right to privacy on the internet the
same way people have a right to privacy
in real life, right? Um so I I do have
very few hard lines, but when I do have
those hard lines, I I I you know am very
strict about them. Uh, so when Food
Shops was trying to justify Dicker's
docs and by, you know, proxy justify my
docs, justify Queen's docs, uh, justify
Jto's docs, justify all these people's
docs. Um, to me, it's kind of like,
okay, yeah, I'm kind of done. I don't,
you know, I don't give a [__] at this
point. Like, no, I'm not going to change
the thumbnail. Uh, no, I'm not going to
change the title. I'm not going to do
any of this [__] Like, absolutely not.
Um,
1,000%.
I do have hard lines when it comes to
certain things and I am I am relatively
strict about those hard lines. Um, I'll
even handle people that are like I I'm
even fine with lollycons. I've talked to
lollycons on stream. I'll can probably
talk to more on stream. Um, I think it's
interesting content. I think it's
entertaining content. Like there there
are things that I can deal with. There
are things that I can 10,00% deal with,
right? Um but like no, I'm not going to
like uh I I guess positively associate
with you if you're going to justify my
docs and say that I deserve to be doxed
because I'm critical of Destiny and what
you describe what you describe as uh as
going after someone's job is criticizing
them. That is [__] ridiculous. That
is [__] absolutely ridiculous.
You should be able to criticize people.
You 1,000% should be able to crit. That
is insane.
That's [__] ridiculous. But anyways,
let's finish the clip.
>> Just call me PDF in the title.
Insane.
>> Look at Jeffrey Epste issue. Okay.
People are bursting at the seams in
their pants the moment they think of
kids being raped. All right. It's
extremely effective. There there is
nothing that turns on people more than
kids. Okay.
>> Chops pedophile manif. What was that?
What?
Huh? What?
W
Okay, there went I'm getting mogged
right now, dude. I'm getting [__]
mogged right now. That's my bad.
What is this man?
The dension day book. Food shops or cat.
I'm food shops. What?
Dude,
this is a 30-page document.
It feels so good to [__] be myself.
[__] some kids. You know, I'm a
[__] pedophile. Yeah, I'm a
[__] pedophile. It's not a
joke. I'm a [__] pedophile.
Wow. W clip. This This chirp mullet guy.
Let me get this tweet. I'm going to
retweet this. This is a very good tweet.
I'm going to like and retweet. This is a
very good tweet. You love a clipper. I'm
going to follow this guy.
You love a clipper that's willing to put
in some editing work uh to get the value
out of a full tweet. That's good. That's
good. I like that. I'll even put this in
chat. I'll even put this in chat.
There's a new account it looks like.
Thank you unidentified crypted for the
10 memberships. Jesus, insanely
generous. Thank you. Oh my goodness. I
appreciate it, man. That is a lot. 10
gifted. I appreciate it. That That is
going to go a long way. Thank you very
much. I appreciate it. Smile.
Sorry, one sec. I'm responding to a DM.
All right.
Are there any other tweets? Any other
tweets on the tweet marathon before we
move on to the Mr. Girl call-in?
Any other tweets? I'll look at a few
other tweets. I'm glad to look at
tweets. I'm a big I'm a big tweet
consumer.
Okay. I'm a big tweet consumer.
Um
dead air. Dead air.
Uh
all right. Let me look.
Dead air maxing. True. Rose Malay
followed me on Twitter.
She locked down her I saw this. Did I
save this tweet?
Oh yeah, they're literally just
fear-mongering on Twitter as well. There
are some tweets that I saved actually
that I forgot about.
Queen and Orbiter Purple Perry Gaming is
keeping a spreadsheet of who is
currently spreading Willie Mac Show or
not. Blue highlight seems to be pro
Willy while orange seems to be
anti-willy. Totally not keeping a list
around for who knows what.
So it it's just like a complete double
standard. It is a complete and utter
double standard. They're complaining.
Obviously the insinuation here is
doxing, right? Obviously the insinuation
here is doxing. It goes without saying.
Uh, the insinuation here is doxing. I
feel like that's fair to say, right?
They're like, "Oh, who knows what
smile?" Like, yeah, they're they're
saying Perry is going to dox people. I
think that is the insinuation that at
least I get. That at least I get. Okay.
Um,
so it's just a complete and utter double
standard. It's like, okay, so you're
you're complaining when someone
associated with Quean does this, but
then Destiny, it's perfectly fine. And
again, I don't I don't like doing the
pure like hypocrisy hunting [__] I
think that's generally pretty qu uh que
[__] cringe. Um I think there's a time
and a place for it.
Um I think right now is is a good time
and a place for it generally. Uh like
yeah, this is just complete and total
fear-mongering. I don't think Perry's
going to dox anybody. It's a [__]
spreadsheet. Who cares? Like it's funny.
Uh, and even then it's just like a
complete and utter double standard. And
then we have this tweet. Food shops
criticism not welcome. Food shops blocks
comments on their debate with dickers.
And you can see the comments right here
are fully disabled.
So, I don't know if this is something
they do on all of their streams where
they disable comments.
And we have a a good epic thumbnail.
Save this picture of food shop. Max,
send me this picture of food shops. If I
make a video on them, I'm definitely
going to use this in the thumbnail. Um,
but yeah, no, this person is just like
complete wretched, spineless, double
standard hypocrite. uh complete just
like complete just freak. Like this is
this is [__] Like you are you are
you are silencing people from commenting
on this which again I'm not going to
make any hard claims here because I they
could do this for every stream. The same
way like I unlist my streams and put
them in a playlist so they're not pushed
in the algorithm and stuff like that.
That the same way they could, you know,
have a reason for turning off comments
on maybe all their streams. I don't know
if this is specific to this. I don't
really care to look into it. Um, but if
that is the case, like sure, obviously
I'll take that back. But if that is
specific to just this stream, that is
ridiculous. That is complete and utter
just like open cowardice. Um, and again,
this is just like deplorable to me. This
is just deplorable to me. So he he feeds
into he he literally raids into an
admitted small pe who is farming his
minor child
who's being farmed by Drew Pavlau.
There's a
>> I watched a little bit of it. Do you
pull this clip? Hold on. Do I got it
here? Where's my Chud clip?
>> I feel
>> Do you Did you know Connor came in like
moralized to Chud about platforming food
shops? Did you get this this bit brought
in?
>> Um I saw that a couple days ago. I
didn't play it on stream though. I know
of it. I know that it exists.
>> I just think it's funny watching drop
another one of his uh principles that
like he's definitely not going to do
anything about this. He's just going to
like, oh, that that principle that you
know, my friend's totally. Yeah. What
can you do, guys? We got to beat Trump
at what what do you think the actual
breaking point for Connor is? I feel
like this would be a fun pool to start.
What do you think Connor's actual
breaking point with his Destiny guy
would be?
>> Like, if this Destiny guy actually
>> I don't think it's I think it's I think
it's
>> Oh, well, we depending on how strict you
are, we might have gotten there tonight.
Did you catch this one? Hold on.
>> You catch uh
>> Oh, no. Don't tell me.
>> Hold on. Did you catch this one? That
food chops is watching Destiny's minor
son debate Drew Pavloo and Destiny raids
into food chops while she's doing that.
>> Did he know?
>> Did he know that his son was being
watched or did he know that this
person's a I'm guessing that he knew
both? But he probably deny both.
>> Bro,
that's rough. Jesus. Have you seen um I
know it's not new, but he's Nate's been
tweeting about it. Uh people have been
DMing him like the the clip of Destiny
like sucking and it's so disgusting.
>> Yeah, I don't I generally like
we try to keep off him off the topic or
off topic here, you know,
>> out of bounds. My bad.
>> I brought it up. No, I brought it up,
but it's like uh
>> Yeah, I try not to talk about it because
like it's just Yeah. No,
>> I won't bring It's my bad. I apologize.
>> No, no, no. It's like I've seen people
say that or I've seen Destiny said that,
right? Destiny's complained about that.
So, um, obviously gross. Obviously
people are Yeah.
>> Yeah. No. Yeah. I think that's it's
evil.